[Music]
if you open your eyes and you have a
visual experience that you describe as a
red apple I'll point here this is your
experience inside the cloud most of us
believe that in fact in reality there is
a red apple that would exist even if we
weren't looking that has the shape and
color that we see and if you close your
eyes and your conscious experience
changes to a gray field we still believe
that there is a red apple out there that
would exist even if no one perceived it
that's the standard view that we have
and this is not only the standard view
of most casual observers but it's also
the view of most of my colleagues who
are professional students and
researchers in the area of visual
perception and perception more generally
my PhD adviser David Marr said that
usually our perceptual processing
delivers a true description of what's
there so if I perceive a red apple if
I'm sober and no one's trying to fool me
then chances are there really is a red
apple that would be there even if no one
if no living creature could could could
see it and Mara went on to say that we
compute explicit properties of the real
visible surfaces out there so there is a
real world out there with with
three-dimensional shapes and surfaces
and your visual system in the normal
case recovers those three-dimensional
surfaces accurately and we get more
objective aspects of the visual world so
we're more and more we're evolving to
see the truth objectively about about
the world Robert rivers who is one of
the foremost evolutionary theorists and
social evolutionary theory for the last
30 or 40 years also has said that our
sense organs have evolved to give us a
detailed and accurate view of reality so
vision scientists first-rate
evolutionary biologists or evolutionary
theorists say this and there's also
another branch of perception that this
is called embodied cognition kinds of
folks and they also say there is an
animal independent world and some of our
perceptions and thoughts get it right so
again is this the consensus and the
textbooks say evolutionarily speaking
vision is useful precisely because it's
so accurate so the idea is this those of
our ancestors who saw more accurately
had a competitive advantage compared to
those who saw less accurately and so
they were more likely to pass on their
genes that code for the more accurate
perception so after thousands of
generations of this competition we can
be quite confident that we're the
offspring of those who saw more
accurately and so in the normal case we
perceived the world quite accurately and
that seems like just obvious right
surely it's more fit to see the truth
than not to see the truth and so most of
my colleagues think that perception is a
process of reconstruction so that the
reason we see reality as it is is
because our visual system is really has
been shaped by evolution to reconstruct
the truth about the world I'll give you
just a couple examples though that that
will start to make you wonder
so in this hat I have a brown rectangle
and a yellow one are they the same color
or different well they're in fact
exactly the same RGB values so I did
this in Photoshop this has exactly the
same RGB values as that and yet we see
one is yellow and one is brown so what's
going on here is that the visual system
is not just seeing like a camera taking
a snapshot
we're actually constructing the colors
that we see and this is by the way a
standard view in the field so I'm not
saying anything that's unusual at this
point
this one is something that you can check
out for yourself the top probably looks
dark gray this looks sort of white or
light gray they're exactly the same
shade of gray and this one you can check
for yourself that I'm not cheating if
you close one eye and put your finger up
so that it covers this gap you'll see
that they're exactly the same does
everybody get that it looks exactly the
same so and we didn't put anything in
your coffee so it's you know this is
this is you so your visual system isn't
seeing the the rock truth it is a
constructive process but but the idea
for from my field is that all of these
constructions that we're doing of shapes
and colors and so forth we're doing it
to try to get as accurate and and a
vertical perception of the world as
possible so vertical means a true
perception of the world and the idea is
as I said that vertical perceptions are
fitter this is on the test no no so it
turns out we don't have to wave our
hands the intuitive argument that I gave
you from evolution is it seems
compelling intuitively but we don't have
to wave our hands evolution by natural
selection is now a mathematically
precise theory we have the tools of what
it's called evolutionary game theory an
evolutionary graph theory and an genetic
algorithm so we can actually test and
about ten years ago I decided to test
well what I believed and what most of my
colleagues believed and the key notion
in the equations that's the replicator
equation which governs natural selection
the key notion that we'd have to
understand and it is something called
Fitness and we've all heard about
Fitness but but what is Fitness as an
evolutionary concept so you get out that
think about a t-bone steak and ask how
many fitness points are what fitness
benefits would that offer to say a
hungry lion well for a hungry lion a lot
of fitness benefits for a t-bone steak
but if that line was full and it was
looking to mate the net t-bone steak
offers no fitness points whatsoever
right and for a rabbit in any state and
for any action that t-bone steaks not
going to do it anything
so fitness points as they are used in
evolutionary theory depend on the world
whatever the world might be but they
also depend very heavily on the organism
lion versus rabbit versus human it's
state hungry versus full and the action
feeding fighting fleeing mating all you
know the famous for us so so all of
these these fitness functions then do
depend on the world but critically on
the organism at state and the action so
it's a so Fitness functions are gonna be
these complicated things this is a nice
little fitness function that says you
know for as the state of the world
changes how the fitness points are going
to change so for one more example being
5000 meters underwater is really bad for
me but it's great for a benthic fish
right what's perfect high Fitness for
one organism is bad for another so this
is a technical question does natural
selection actually favor
true perceptions have we been shaped to
see reality as it is and I'm not going
to go into that through them I'll just
state the result the result is the
probability is zero that natural
selection will favor an organism that
sees reality as it is we came at this
with evolutionary game simulations in
which we actually we create about a
million different random worlds with
resources and then we put creatures that
could see the whole world exhaustively
and truly and they competed against
creatures that saw none of reality and
we're just tuned to the fitness payoffs
the creases that some reality as it is
one extinct when they competed against
those who didn't see reality as it is
we're just too into fitness so after I
did that with my graduate students for a
few years I went with a mathematician
and we proved a theorem the the theorem
is this evolution by natural selection
will drive a creature to extinction that
sees truth if it competes against
another creature of equal complexity
that sees none of the truth and has just
tuned to the relative fitness payoffs
the idea is something like this
intuitively suppose you're playing a
video game you're trying to grab points
quickly as you can to get to the next
level of the game if you don't get
enough points you don't you die you
don't go to the next level of the game
if you do anything except focus on
getting those points you're gonna lose
and that's the same thing in evolution
by natural selection you don't go to the
next level your children go to the next
level if you succeed if evolution shaped
our perceptions to do anything else
except chase Fitness payoffs then you're
playing the wrong game it's very much
like someone playing chess that's
hunting for pawns instead of the kingdom
it's the wrong game looking for truth is
like hunting for pawns you're not
playing the right game the only game is
Fitness payoffs so and Fitness payoffs
can be very very interesting if you have
say the case of oxygen if you have too
little oxygen you die if you have too
much oxygen you die if you have just the
right narrow amount of oxygen you're
fine so suppose that you're an organism
and you only have two perceptions red
and green and evolution is going to try
to shape you with those two perceptions
to deal with the oxygen problem right
getting enough oxygen
now there's two strategies that you
could think about here one is a truth
strategy so I'm going to set up my red
and green perceptions to tell me as much
as possible about how much oxygen there
really is in the world so green would
mean in that case lots of oxygen red
would mean not as much oxygen so from
there from the red and green perceptions
you would be able to say how much oxygen
there was as much as you could tell with
just two colors right that would be as
maximally informative about the truth
about how much oxygen there is but
here's here's a different strategy I'm
going to use the same red and green
colors but I'm going to do it this way
red means bad payoffs green means good
payoffs
same two colors but a different mapping
from the world into my perceptions I
can't tell you how much oxygen there is
in the world
red could mean a whole lot or very very
little I've erased knowledge about the
truth all I know is that it's really
safe where it's green and it will kill
me
where it's red so if I start seeing
green I'm good if I see red whatever I
don't care what the world is if it's red
do something different if it's green
keep doing what you're doing
here you have no idea if you're going to
die or not you're seeing the truth and
the truth will make you extinct for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the institute of arts and ideas
at iai TV
you